à
cécile non je te coucher des enfants oui
tu perds ta ka les emmener avec vous au
portugal tap à des vacances milou
hommage à
amy tellement hâte de voir la maison
il m
c'est la merde
la maison n'est pas fini on est au
milieu d'un chantier olivier il profite
la vieillesse des gens les vieux ils
sont plus naïfs que les autres personnes
c'est comme pour
un régime d'averses a travaillé à tirer
sur la corde elle a certainement ça je
comprends je parle en général sékou
patate new monsieur alves nous propose
de terminer les travaux multi dès
maintenant il fait pas tout seul
pas traîné au passage
on va y aller pas se faire engueuler oui
mais chez rick celle hicks et gillett
dormir attendent ils sont où les enfants
pour ma chérie faut vraiment que je te
dise
pas tout va monter ton petit lit et
non au nom au [ __ ] [ __ ] je reste à
une seconde de plus dans cette maison
je passe les pires vacances de ma vie
dans un pays gouverné
non oui non mais les gens se garent
n'importe comment ici tant qu'il y est
monté
[Musique]
oh je crois qu'ils sont rendus compte
quelque chose au nom
[Musique]
s'est réveillé d'un coup